take one the young a super successful
entrepreneur Evan Carmichael is here
Evan Carmichael Evan Carmichael believe
this guy is a force of nature Evan
Carmichael is an entrepreneurial expert
my name is Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs when I was
young I had a whole bunch of different
business ideas that my first venture was
when I was five years old and I
convinced my three-year-old little
sister to selling art and doing garage
sales and selling baseball cards small
ventures when I was growing up in high
school I never thought it was gonna be
an entrepreneur I thought it's gonna be
a VP at a bank when I was in university
I met up with two friends and they had a
business that that would they were
trying to get off the ground as a
software company and they put so much
into this company but it wasn't taking
off but I joined it I became an owner
and the chief operating officer and in
my final year I got job opportunities
which only a few years prior would have
been a dream scenario
I couldn't imagine working for a better
company but something just didn't feel
right about it up until that point I
always thought I'd have a corporate job
the way I was living was just terrible
but I didn't really mind because I was
doing something that I loved doing that
I hadn't experienced this kind of
excitement and passion before my friends
thought I was crazy
starting a business is hard and I wish
somebody told me that when I was
starting my company because the books
make it seem so easy do this do this do
this follow the simple recipe and boom
your success it doesn't happen that way
for the past ten years plus I've built a
business helping entrepreneurs believe
in themselves and build great
organizations so you have to listen to
your heart that's my view you have to
listen to your heart you have to be
passionate about it here's what you have
to know about success as an entrepreneur
success doesn't look like this
okay success is not just a straight line
of success it's it's a bunch of failures
I wish somebody prepared me for it
the idea that you start with is not the
idea that you end with starting the
business is hard but it's still entirely
possible you can do it people often
start for the wrong reasons they start
just trying to make money whenever
you're faced with a major decision in
your business or your life the most
important thing that you can do the best
decision to make is to follow your heart
the biggest question comes down to how
badly do you really want this
so yeah starting a business is hard but
it's totally possible believe